les 20 et 27 juin prochains nous avons
les élections départementales et
régionales
ces élections sont déterminants il
s'agit pas de faire le concours du
meilleur slogan mais la capacité à
exercer des compétences et c'est là que
les républicains excellent regarder le
bilan de nos équipes d'antan dans les
départements que dans les régions que ce
soit sur tout ce qui touche d'ailleurs
la vie quotidienne de nos compatriotes
les collèges les lycées l'agriculture
l'industrie l'économie le tourisme
l'action sociale c'est tout cela qui est
en jeu je vous invite donc à vous
mobiliser très fortement partout dans
tous les départements
toutes les régions à mobiliser vos amis
vos collègues de travail ils vont voter
pour nos listes les républicains
[Musique]